the planets in our solar system emerged
from a vast swirling cloud of ice dust
and gas the same ingredients can still
be found on earth today in places like
Iceland where volcanic ash mixes with
icy glaciers if you want to build a
giant planet like Saturn this pile of
raw material here is a great visual
analogue there's a lot of oxygen and
hydrogen in the universe that makes
water that makes water ice and the stuff
initially that made the solar system is
basically this stuff here it's dirty ice
water ice with a little bit of a little
bit of rocky and metallic minerals left
in there out there in the cold of space
four and a half billion years ago a vast
cloud of dirty ice particles shrouded in
hydrogen and helium collapses under its
own gravity and at the center a new star
our Sun sparks into life the heat of the
new star melts the ice closest to it and
blows away the gas leaving only rocky
debris behind but farther out icy
material and gas survive a boundary
forms a frost line between the rocky
inner cloud and the icy gas beyond once
you fired up that cap fire if you will
what will be left behind in the inner
solar system is gonna be this stuff a
silicate minerals you make a planet like
the earth from but far away from the Sun
where it's colder you cross the frost
line and what's out there is still cold
enough to maintain the the ice behind
and there's a lot of it there at first
you make a sort of a solid core of this
material but when you reach a critical
mass you've got enough gravitational
influence to start to directly draw in
some of the hydrogen and helium in the
interplanetary cloud Saturn's huge solid
core now ten to twenty times the size of
the earth generates relentless gravity
and draws in gas
the bigger this gas ball gets the more
material it sucks in Saturn's massive
gravity then gets to work on its
fledgling atmosphere compressing it at
like any gas under pressure it gets hot
seriously hot even today
Saturn's high-pressure atmosphere heats
its core to 21,000 degrees
twice the temperature of the surface of
the Sun and it's this heat rising up
which forms Saturn's distinct bands and
drives its extreme weather satyr is
actually rotating very quickly
it's a large planet it rotates once on
its axis about every 10 hours so as the
weather comes up from the interior it
gets smeared out into bands
at Saturn's North Pole the bands do
something that at first glance seems
impossible there is a gigantic vortex a
spinning region of air that shaped like
a perfect hexagon you have waves of
pressure density and temperature that
start to interact with each other and
these waves can actually interfere and
become one big wave that goes all the
way around the planet